uh i guess i'll preface this game by
saying that this was
a really it was from the uh emery koenig
memorial tournament in san francisco
uh it took place i'm trying to remember
exactly when this game took place it did
not take place in 2020 which is actually
really funny i think it's because i
threw this into a lychee study and then
threw it out of one or something
but i'm trying to remember the year of
this game it's actually it was a long
long time ago though i think it was
i want to say 2007. 2007 it was before i
became a gm
so
quite honestly if you're asking about
chess base i think it's good for any
level if you're serious about studying
chess and you're serious about
inputting your games and searching games
chess base is an invaluable tool
you can get by without it more now than
you used to be able to but it's just
good if you play in tournaments and play
people who you can look up and
have like openings you databases you
want to prepare and stuff like that
in any case this was one of the more
memorable games i've had in my career
um it was really quite a fun game to
play and uh
it was i haven't looked at it in a very
long time so i reviewed it for this
lecture and stuff like that but i really
wanted to
show it because it has so many
instructive points
and overall it just was really even
though i ended up losing the game it was
one of the most memorable games i played
and i really enjoyed it and i wanted to
share it with you guys
so i can share kind of some of the
lessons i've learned from it myself
so to start with back in those days
this was pre-2010 so i was primarily an
e4 player back then
nowadays i play mostly d4 but back then
e4 was my primary weapon
uh e45 knight f3 and c6 bishop b5
so we played the lopez or spanish knight
f6
castles bishop v7 rookie 1 b5
bishop b3 in castles so
he decided to go with this his wife was
actually playing in the tournament as
well
and she also played a lopez slightly
different than this
uh but i got a very good position
against her and i was able to win pretty
decisively so i think he mixed it up and
i think in general this is just kind of
what he plays so
it's quite normal um
but yeah so these days i didn't really
play mainline marshall very much i could
i knew some theory but
it wasn't really my style to honestly to
play up the pawn and what i mean is by
playing the main line marshall you play
with c3
you allow d5 pawn takes you grab this
pawn
and then after c6 you can play d3 or d4
and then bishop d6 your rook goes back
black puts the queen on h4 so for
example let's say here
queen h4 you play g3 queen h3 and life
kind of continues it's very very sharp
and interesting
but in general black gets a lot of
compensation for being down the pawn
and this was never really my style of
play i preferred to sack the pawn and
not
have someone sack against me so in those
days i played various types of
anti-marshals
and one of the ones i really enjoyed at
that time was this move d4
so d4 is kind of an unknown move a
little bit for a lot of people
but it's actually quite interesting so
there are lots of ways you can proceed
here
uh you could take the pawn with the pawn
but the problem with this is that after
e598
i have several good options i can play
knight takes d4 which is mostly
simple i have bishop d5 which can be
annoying but in general this knight on
e8 is just not
not really great in this particular
scenario and the knight on c6 is pretty
annoying because of the pin
so normally they either play knight
takes d4 if they don't play what he
played in the game
i don't think d4 is necessarily not good
by the way i think that it's
if black knows what they're doing
usually they get an equal position right
but
you could say that about almost any
opening so to call d4 bad is probably a
bit much but i would definitely say that
there are different ways to play
so after knight takes d4 you can play
knight takes d4 but there's also a very
fun line where you play bishop takes f7
check
rook takes f7 knight takes e5 and the
whole idea here is that if they try to
move the knight back and you take on
f7 you get exc you get a huge amount of
play
uh so for example if knight comes back
knight takes and i think king e5 and
already queen f3 check is coming like
this is kind of a disaster
so normally black just retreats and
white's actually up a pawn here but
black gets enormous
compensation with something like this uh
it's still very unclear even shook one a
really really nice game in this line
that's quite famous but in general i
don't really care for it too much
uh so i i you know knight takes d4 is
the main thing i would play
takes e5 98 and here you have different
options you can play with c3
uh and basically sacrifice a pawn in
order to get activity something like
this
followed by knight d5 and you get a lot
of activity for the pawn
again if black really knows what they're
doing they're probably just fine but you
could argue that about most lines
queen takes d4 is also quite playable
and the idea is that after c5 you play
queen e4 hitting the rook on a8
and then black plays rook b8 and now you
can play either c3 or c4
both of which lead to kind of
interesting games the knight on e8 is
definitely bad but black also
has a slight lead in development with
other pieces because my queen size not
developed
so i would say that it's definitely kind
of an unclear position but very
interesting
most players however don't do any of
this they most players just play d6
and the reason for this is because black
really white really has nothing better
than to defend the d-pawn with c3
you can go for these kind of lines these
are this is actually quite playable
but black has all sorts of options like
a lot of the options i think they just
even just take back and put the bishop
on c5 and
these end games are kind of harmless in
general so i would say that this is not
the most
um interesting way to play although it's
definitely possible
um so you kind of play c3 and now you've
actually transposed to what would be a
d4 lopez so the normal move order for
this is let's say c3 d6 and
most players play h3 here and now there
are lines like
knight a5 which is trigorin there's
rookie a bishop b7 which is zaitsev
there's knight b8 d7 which is briar
this would be kind of the standard lopez
which has existed for a long time
um but it you can also have the option
of playing d4 here
right away and you kind of transpose to
this but the drawback is you allow
bishop g4 as a move
so to give you an idea that's actually
what we transpose to which is why most
people play d6 because
you transpose to this kind of sideline
so now bishop g4 is played
and this pin is quite annoying on the
knight so there are two main options for
white in a position like this you can
play
d5 which is what i did or you can play
bishop e3
and bishop e3 is pretty
interesting as a line like a lot of
people i'd say this is more common these
days now
and one of the really common tricks here
is that if what black tries to grab this
pawn is actually a big mistake because
you can play bishop d5
and you actually fork the two knights so
kind of a nice little trick
and again this opening stuff is not
necessary for the game but
you know a lot of people like to learn
about openings so i'm just kind of
showing you some basics
so usually what black will do is they'll
take and play knight a5 instead
and then either knight c4 bishop c1 c5
or c5 immediately
and they're trying to combat the center
that way and use the active bishop on g4
and these lines are quite interesting
i've had quite a few
pretty crazy games in these lines
so d5 was what i chose against italic
for what it's worth those who don't know
swara talk like he's a very very
experienced very strong gm
originally from yugoslavia i believe but
now
resides in turkey and very very
experienced quite strong
and i forget what his peak rating was
but you know quite a bit experience and
at the time i was a pretty strong i am
like 24 70 or so but i definitely wasn't
gm level yet
um so he was definitely the higher rated
player and the
you know the stronger player and um but
at the same time obviously you know
we're just playing a game right so
anything can happen
but yeah this game like both of us were
actually analyzing this game i think at
the table
even though this game lasted i think
about six hours almost it was a very
long game
we ended up analyzing this game at the
table for like at least an hour
even though we were both exhausted
because of how fun it was to play
so bishop c2 uh you almost never want to
give
up that bishop now c6 and the whole
point of c6
is that you're trying to undermine this
d-pawn if the pawn were already on c5
like you could even play c5 here if you
so wanted the problem is that now
my central advantage with e4 d5 against
e5 d6 is permanent and that's not the
end of the world
like it's playable but it's not really
what black wants if black can
try to chip away at my center it's
definitely a lot better
and how's it going chess king so this is
all kind of theory but i'm just trying
to explain the moves a little bit
um so yeah so
why could play d take c6 but it's
actually considered a bit more accurate
to play h3 first at least it was back
then
and the whole point is that now the
bishop doesn't have a particular square
if you play dtx6 first
and say queen c7 which is the normal
idea and then h3
black has the option of playing bishop
e6 right away
and this is actually quite convenient
because after h3 black has a lot of
options but one option they don't have
is bishop back to e6 which is the nicest
square
so if they can try many many options
here by the way
you can play bishop takes f3 as a move
and then you play queen takes
takes takes and usually black tries to
target this pawn so they'll go for ideas
like this
but white often will sacrifice it and
the two bishops will be
quite a bit of compensation for this
pawn so again this
is playable black has the option of
playing bishop h5
as well but the drawback to this move is
that sometimes later in the game the
bishop gets shot out of the game
and that tends to be a little
unfavorable but i would also say that
this is definitely a possibility as well
um and there's also this move bishop d7
and this move i actually faced i i
played one of my favorite games that i
played
against this move and one of the cool
tricks white has i'll see if any of you
actually find it because i realize i've
been babbling and i like to ask
questions even during these youtube
lectures so
what would you what do you guys think
white has here there's no win of a
material or anything but there's a
really cute tactical trick
which does something pretty neat
so basically find a tactical trick for
white that only wins the two bishops
so what do you guys think
very good yeah so this is what happened
in that game i played knight takes e5
what's funny is at the time i didn't
really know about this trick
so i just kind of had to find it over
the board but
i found it and then d6 and the idea is
that you just win the two bishops and
it's not much but usually you have a
little bit of an advantage in these
positions
so it's kind of a nice little trick in
this line
uh that's worth noting uh you can play
yeah so the main move believe it or not
is bishop all the way back to c8
and this move it looks really strange
but the idea is that your bishop doesn't
want to get shot out of the game with h5
you don't want to give it up with bishop
takes f3 and you don't want to play
bishop d7 allowing the trick
so c8 becomes your only square so a lot
of people kind of play these moves
without thinking
and i really like to know the purpose of
why i'm playing moves
in the opening or in any part of the
game so bishop c8 looks like such a
strange move and i wouldn't want to pass
it by without explaining it
so it takes on c6 and now once again you
don't really want to take the pawn right
away
because if you do your knight on c6 is
just not a good piece because
it's blocked by this pawn there are a4
options sometimes and in general it's
just harder to defend the d5 square
which is the weak square
if you take right away if by the way
what opening would you say this
resembles now more than a lopez
uh yeah i'm sure italic annotates lots
of games i mean he's very very famous
gm as far as like he's done annotations
he's done
fair share of coaching i want to say but
he's also just been around a long time
and in general just a very high caliber
of player
yeah i've known so at a long time yeah
bishop d3 queen e2 is possible
uh but what opening does this resemble
would you guys say it is like a
slain right kind of like a night or
where
you know black's gotten an a6 b5 but
basically you have a sicilian structure
you've traded the d-pawn for the c-pawn
i would say closest to a night or
and it's really funny because people
often don't realize that they're playing
a night or now i definitely didn't when
i played this way back when
so it's kind of funny when i look at it
now and i didn't realize i was playing a
night or
um as white but yeah i mean once you
know that the pawn structure changes and
you're aware of it it actually can help
you
play the positions a little bit better i
would say
um but yeah just in general
it's you know it's good to know kind of
why you're playing moves
so the whole point of queen c7 is that
you really want to try to aim to control
the d5 square a bit better
so after knight d2 and then queen takes
c6 all of a sudden you're really
controlling that square
and the knight often coming to c4 can be
quite annoying
so um in general this is kind of the way
what black wants to play
so i played knight f1 he played rookie 8
which is normal enough just kind of an
improving move like it doesn't do
anything too special but it just
improves the position
yeah and a lot of people don't and you
don't have to know opening names that
well but it's more that
if you're aware of how a structure works
it helps you play it a little bit better
the lopez incidentally can transpose
into so many structures i've shown
people how the lopez can actually
transpose into a moran
which is a d4 opening and they just
don't believe it they're like how is
this even possible
but it's a very versatile opening which
is one of the reasons why it's one of my
favorites
uh this is the early c3 d4 i forget the
technical name for it
but without h3 basically in the main
line
so knight g3 knight to c4
and now a4 a very typical move in any
kind of
lopez position where you're basically
trying to undermine the b5 pawn and make
life a little bit uncomfortable for
black so there are two main moves here
one which i like bet a bit better is to
play bishop e6
so you guard the d5 and f5 squares is
the advantage of it
um and it's just kind of centralized
it's just kind of a nice square right
you can also play bishop to b7 and
bishop b7 has the advantage of
being more active so you're ready to
kind of play d5 and try to target the
pawn
the drawback of bishop v7 however is
that you allow knight f5 which is not
something i'm crazy about
um so
yeah so knight to b6
was what he chose instead and knight b6
is what i would call a provocative move
so basically he's
um he's attacking the a4 pawn trying to
force my hand
and trying to improve his pieces but
he's not developing his bishop he's not
actually developing a piece
and during the game i found this move to
be very provocative like i really didn't
like it
and i i just had an instinct for an
initiative here and i would say that
my instinct was correct like this move
should not be that great
but i also think that i didn't quite
execute it very well and i think it's
because i didn't calculate it well
enough
so what i'm going to have you guys do is
to kind of do what i
try to play like me except play better
basically so this
particular decision i made was correct i
think because you have the choice here
of taking on b5 or playing a5
so which move do you think uh you would
go for
so take it take a minute maybe and
decide between eight takes b5 and a5
which movie would you go for
so we have a couple a takes b fans or
three
most guys want to take okay
all right we won an a5 guy all right
yeah so it's actually a very difficult
choice i think
actually recently i think it was done
near dubois or some guy like this had
this as white and he played a takes b5
and after pawn takes rook takes knight
takes the game kind of peered out to a
draw it's just
not much is going on here honestly like
you haven't really achieved much i feel
like a4 is kind of wasted
and yes the knights on a8 but it comes
back to c7 or the b6 next move
i don't really think you're doing that
much and during the game i wanted to try
to get an initiative and the advantage
of a5 is that it
keeps more pieces on the board forces
the knight to move again and i feel like
this is a better
more initiative driven move it has
positional risks by the way because if
you play a5 you're taking pressure up
the b5 pawn
so there are definite drawbacks to
playing this move but i feel like
because you're
getting this initiative because you're
cramping black's position a little bit
i think it's the better move so this was
what was played in the game and i think
this decision was correct
knight bd7 and then this position is
actually kind of interesting so
i played the move knight f5 which i felt
had to be correct and looked natural
and it's probably not a bad move like
knight f5 can't be a terrible move
but i
could have played this move knight h4
and the idea is that after g6 i play
queen f3
and just the idea of having bishop h6
and knight f5 is just super annoying
here the queen on f3 is a very good
piece
and if the knight ever moves then i can
sometimes bring the bishop back to
b3 and this pawn is also a target so
this kind of position actually could be
very very dangerous for black uh but
during the game i plopped mine on f5 i
thought how could this be wrong
and it's not terrible but maybe not the
most accurate and now bishop f to f8
which is typical that's the reason why
black puts the rook on e8 by the way
and now bishop g5 so the idea of bishop
g5 is i don't want him to be able to
play knight c5 and target my pawn so
easily
because now his knight on f6 is attacked
so he can't just move his knight
so easily and it means that this knight
at f5 is hard to get rid of
so i was very happy with my position
here but my opponent definitely did not
panic he played bishop b7
um just improving a piece so i did the
same thing i played queen d2
and yeah here he plays a move which
maybe is a bit
too much like he probably has to try and
move like h6 here
i understand why he didn't want to do
this i think he didn't want to make too
many
kinkside moves here but i think that the
idea is that if bishop h4
and by the way trying to sacrifice just
doesn't work i could try takes takes
uh but then knight h7 for example and
i don't really have enough of an attack
here to justify this so
probably it's not the best so probably
here i should play bishop back to h4
instead
and then just rook c8 and it looks like
i have a lot of pressure but my
follow-up's actually not so simple
and he's gonna play b4 next i think one
of you pointed this point
this idea out and b4 might be really
really annoying with a takes b
b takes c coming in uh i don't know
actually actually maybe not b4
immediately because there's bishop a4
but b4 as an idea in general could be
quite annoying and d5 is always on the
horizon
so it's actually not so easy to
to do anything amazing in this position
so maybe he should have tried this
instead
he played queen c7 though which actually
is very logical
um but then here i think i came up with
an idea and i was very very happy with
my idea
during the game but it's probably not
objectively best but you'll see why i
was happy with it in a moment because
the whole concept is a little bit funny
um
but what did you guys do here as white i
think that i have a way to play which is
quite clear and quite decent
knight h2 to g4 is really tempting it
looks really good to me i like your idea
rook d1 chess king exactly and simply
playing rook d1
is just good here so i think during the
game i was a little nervous about
opening leaving my a5 pawn but honestly
this is kind of silly
uh i have a lot of ways to play here but
it turns out the best is actually bishop
takes f6
and then a very nasty move queen g5 and
this move is just
really all kinds of horrible because
knight h7
net h6 is going to be a whole lot of not
fun
and in addition rook takes f6 as a
threat rick takes d6 as a threat
so for example if king h8 you simply
take on d6 and you can't ever take back
because the g7
pawn and here you're threatening this
you're threatening
oh it's just horrible like this is just
dead
um now this isn't always so easy to see
during the game like you're not always
looking for this kind of tactic but this
position is just atrocious
and nothing good will ever come of
of black's position here um
yeah exactly nice king and the queen on
a5 is really bad so i think
i think this is what worried me during
the game and i don't know why d5 i
looked at as well
but here i can actually just build and
probably this would be maybe was
something i missed as well that i could
just play net h2 which was your idea
before
uh to harry but after takes knight g4
and those knights are just
really very awkward here and the
pressure on black's position is truly
enormous
so i think that this position will be
really really unpleasant for black
um but yeah i think that after maybe
after d5 knight h2 is what i missed
remember i played this game about
14 15 years ago almost so i don't
remember everything perfectly
to say the least but okay bishop h4 is
what i played and this move looks
extremely mysterious
um and if i looked at it now i'm kind of
going really
but i had a very very i would say clever
idea behind this move
so he played d5 and now once again i got
too clever
i should just play the move bishop b3
and this move just looks really really
nice to me
because the whole idea is that if you
try a knight takes seat e4 i can play
takes and then knight g5
and i don't know if this is that easily
winning
or that i would spot it that simply but
it does look very good for white and one
of the key lines which
i definitely didn't see this was
something when i uh computer checked it
later was that after takes takes
apparently the best move here
by far is queen d1
g5 is not quite the idea you'll see khan
but and apparently queen d1 is
absolutely
atrocious for black because queen h5 is
coming
and if this move then bishop g3 and this
pressure on e5 is really annoying
and somehow black's position just
completely falls apart here
like you just lose because for example
if takes i can simply play queen h5 and
you get mated
and the pressure on e5 is really
annoying you're throwing just to take
the rook at some point
uh apparently this is just dead dead
lost but this is not something that's
easy for a human being to see right away
but i would say that if i had spotted
bishop e3 in the exchange stack with
knight g5 i think i would have gone for
it this just looks really really
good and even if i don't spot this queen
d1 move i probably could have found my
way to a good position here
so probably i should have gone this but
i was drawn to a particular idea
i played pawn takes d5 bishop takes d5
and here i played the move knight g5
and i think at this point he had a very
confused look on his face
because he didn't quite go what i was
going for the knights look threatening
but he plays h6
the question is what was my idea here
what do you guys think
so knight takes f7 is possible but i
don't really understand what the idea is
if say bishop takes f7 do i have an idea
here
okay you can take on h6 but i feel like
you're actually just giving away your
pieces because everything's very well
defended for black the pieces are all
kind of grouped together nicely so i
definitely don't
see how that works so knight takes f7 is
not correct
no problems thanks for tuning in at such
an hour
hope you don't regret it tomorrow though
4 25am
very good jonathan net h7
i don't know it's it's one of those
moves that
you just really like playing because it
it's such a
crazy move right and i remember actually
uh there was a game that when i was at a
a chess camp where i was teaching but i
was i
would sneak into like at the time i
would think i was an fm and i would
sneak into gm's lecturing and one of
them was
gm alex golden who later became a coach
of mine and he had a game where he was
showing how to play defense and he had a
game where he was black against even
chook
and even took through this knight and
threw a knight h5 idea at him in a
similar position
and it was this really powerful idea and
got him a big positional advantage and
golden managed to defend and draw he's a
very very good defender
but that game kind of struck me so i
thought ned h7 was like net h5 on the
next level you know
but yeah the idea is basically i'm not
just trying to be cute i'm trying to
undermine the f6 knight is the whole
idea
um so i was very very happy with this
move i recall
again i wasn't sure it really led to
anything special for me i didn't think i
was even that much
that great but i just recall really
enjoyed playing the move
it's definitely one of the more unusual
ideas that you can play a move like this
in your opponent's territory where
they have two pieces that can capture it
right
um but objectively it's definitely like
a decent idea it's not bad
but it's not so easy to actually go
anywhere
but one of the things you'll encounter
about experienced jams like italic is
that they never panic almost ever
and a lot of players i think when they
face a move like this which they don't
anticipate and he definitely didn't
expect it
i don't believe they often react poorly
or they'll panic or they'll do something
crazy either too aggressive or too
passive or
something like this but i would say that
one of the really great things you can
learn from italic
who is black here is that he did not
panic at all he just thought for a while
and realized that he has to take with
the king and took with the king
so my idea now is that i play 97 check
hitting the bishop so i'm basically just
winning my material back right
but he plays bishop e4 which is a decent
idea
because he doesn't really want to let me
take his bishop for free if he moves his
king back here for example
and i take his bishop this would be a
big success for me because now i have
the two bishops in a position where the
two bishops look very very strong
so i don't think he'd really want to
allow a position like this
so he plays bishop e4
and here once again i continue kind of
the aggressive trend i play the move
knight d5
so once again the idea is that he can't
take with the bishop and if he takes
with the knight
then i don't know
i take with i take on e4 with check and
i take the knight and my two bishops
again are very very strong
so it's not really what he wants so
probably he should move his queen a
different square than what he played
here
um maybe the best is queen c4 which
actually
forces me to play b3 which looks silly
but the idea is that after queen c6 now
rook takes e4 he can simply retreat and
the funny thing here is that
he took the b3 square is now taken away
from my bishop and beat and c3 is a
weaker pawn
so believe it or not provoking this b3
move is
quite a quite an annoying idea um
but okay this is again not something
which i feel is so easy to see
uh but objectively this is probably
around equal with best play he played
queen d6 which probably is less accurate
but here unfortunately i
didn't give my other opportunities a
fair shake like i think
at this point i just really thought i
was about equal and again i gave up on
it and i ended up taking on f6 i
remember being unhappy but i actually
have something stronger here and maybe
you guys can find it so instead of
knight takes f6 which is what i played
and just tried to take the material back
i have kind of a better way to play
which may have led to a bit of an
advantage for me
so what do you guys think
rookie four is interesting i i think
that it would i think though that he can
take that
so if rook takes e4 for instance i think
he can take
and then drop his king back and i'm not
really sure i'm getting that much for my
exchange to be honest like i definitely
have some kind of compensation but
i don't think it's so clear so i wasn't
sure this was the right way to course of
action
bishop takes up 6 then i think bishop
takes f6 allows what
maybe it would be similar no it wouldn't
be so he can't take back
so what was the deal on bishop takes f6
i think he was just gonna take here
yeah i think this was the issue he would
simply take this and now if queen takes
simply go back to h8 and i have a couple
pieces hanging here which is a little
bit unfortunate for me
so i think i had to be careful i don't
think bishop takes f6 works as well
none of you guys have it quite yet but
maybe but remember you're just winning
an exchange back at most right you're
not winning a whole piece back so
i can play knight takes f6 knight b6
queen c6 take the rook queen takes or
something and i have two pieces for rook
there so it's a nice idea but i don't i
don't think it quite pans out
this move is actually absurdly simple
and obnoxious almost i can actually play
the move rook ad1 here
and believe it or not this is actually
just strong because
he doesn't really have a great move it
turns out the best
thing he could try is to move his king
because he just doesn't really have
another improving move if he tries
taking and i take now knight takes f6 is
a huge problem and he just loses
uh he doesn't really have a great
improving move like knight takes f6 is
always in the air
he has to always be careful of that so
even though i'm not threatening anything
outrageous
it's just a really strong improving move
so his best
bet is to play king g8 and now i could
play bishop takes e4 and then rook takes
e4
and i think i have a nice advantage here
because my net on d5 is very very strong
and my rooks are very very good in the
center i worry a little bit about my
bishop on h4
but i don't know it's not so easy to
actually trap that thing
and i feel like my pieces in the center
are going to be very very good here so
i think this gives me like a bit of an
advantage maybe not decisive or anything
crazy but
definitely i still would be a little bit
better um
at the very least i would take white in
that position um
but i didn't find it and i liquidated
too early so now the game actually
fizzles out into an end game
and i remember being quite disappointed
here because takes takes here
rook d1 he plays bishop c7
and we trade to this end game and i
remember being disappointed because i'm
like oh man this
this is so dull compared to what we were
having before
um but it turns out this end game also
becomes very very interesting and in
fact in the end
became one of the more interesting rook
end games
uh that i played but let's see how we
got there first of all so i played the
move b4
and this move is
pretty normal i mean i don't really want
to give up the a5 pawn it's not
necessary but i definitely think this
move makes sense
he plays e4 so basically he's saying
that he wants to put a bishop on e5
and target my pawn which makes a lot of
sense
so i play the move bishop e7 so that i
don't end up getting my bishop trapped
or anything embarrassing
bishop e5 and when i looked at this
position later this is one of those
things where i think that
back then i was a bit of a different
player than i am now
one of the things i would say is that
back then i was never too materialistic
but i would say that back then i valued
material a bit
more and structure a bit more than i do
now and i valued activity a bit less
i've definitely picked up a player who
values activity more than i used to
so i think that here i would make a
different decision if i had this game
today than
back then um
and it's not just even about strength
like i'm definitely you know at least
at some point you know i became a
stronger player than i was then maybe a
hundred points higher or so
um you know but not that i was so much
i'm so much stronger now it's more that
i view chess a little differently
so i think that the decision i made then
is different than the one i would make
now
um not even just because of i'm stronger
but because of chess style is just
different
so chest style could really influence
your decisions i guess is the main point
i'm making
um but what would you guys do here
because you have a couple different
options on how to play here
so you were clear i mean the game should
probably end in a draw but at the same
time there's still plenty of life left
and for sure italic is one of those
players who is very very ambitious
especially against low-rated players
about playing for the win
and he doesn't like to give up draws
against almost anyone
so he's someone who's always going to be
pressing his absolute hardest to win and
again i think this is a quality and of
his that you can
try to emulate in your own games because
you could definitely feel the pressure
when you play him more than some other
players who might be very strong but
don't necessarily try to beat you so
badly
so rook d8 i don't really like the main
reason is that if rook d8
simply takes takes takes and i think i'm
just down upon here because
i have to defend and then f5 and king f7
king e6
it feels like i might just lose this
position to be honest so i think this
would be
not the correct approach so i don't
really like rook d a check
um
so what else can we do rookie one is
interesting but the problem with rookie
one is i think
i don't know there are a couple issues
first of all i'm not so crazy about this
allowing this pin i feel like allowing
this pin is
asking for trouble maybe it doesn't lead
anywhere but i would be very nervous
about
allowing this pin because bishop takes
b4 as a threat if f3 then f5 is the
thing
i'm i would not be happy with this pin
so that's at least one reason
i also am not sure about the move f5 and
then bishop takes c3 as a temple move
so if i try f3 for example this is a
tempo and bishop d4 check's also a tempo
so i don't really like rookie one either
so rook d7 has been suggested i like
that move uh i would prefer a slightly
different version of it which is to play
bishop c5 first
so you allow black to capture your pawn
and then play rook d6 and i like this
move better because it pins the rook
down on a8 because now the pawn on a6 is
always hanging
and if you lose the a6 pawn by the way
you're probably just dead lost because
then the apon's way too strong
so when you can force your opponent's
rook to just sit on this square for the
rest of their life
you're probably doing just fine even if
you're down upon
and now for example if they try to go f5
you can play
g4 and try to undermine their pawns you
try to bring your king into the game
and it's just very limited what black
can ever do here because it's so
difficult for black to ever get the rook
in the game because rook takes
a6 is always just going to be very
strong
so i would say that this is probably
what i would do now something like this
and who knows maybe he wouldn't actually
just take right away maybe he would
try something else but the fact is that
maybe next move i'm ready to play rookie
one maybe next move i have rook d5 or
rook d7 as you suggested
and i don't know i don't think it's
going to end up making a huge difference
to be perfectly honest i can play moves
like g4 if i want next move
it's no problem um so i don't know i
would say that this would be a very very
clear path towards a draw
and i think that nowadays i would really
value my rook activity quite a bit more
uh back then i don't think i was as
devoted to that so i played them with
rook c1 basically i just want to get in
the with c4
so he plays f5 improving his position
and i play c4
but the fact is that this is nice i like
i really wanted to be able to play c4
and then b5 and get a very strong a pawn
but this is just not quite realistic
because after rook c8
i really don't want to play c5 myself
because then my bishop's gonna end up
trapped
so i play bishop back to c5 but now
after takes takes i really can't push
anything he plays
king e6 and the problem is that because
my this pin
and my rook being kind of passive i
can't ever really play b5 so even though
i thought this was good because i'd be
able to get in b5
now i realize that well wait a second
now he just brings his king to the game
and what am i doing with my life you
know um
because his king just becomes very very
strong now
and i think this is something which i
appreciate a lot more now than i did
then
the idea of king activity it sounds
basic but the fact is that
his king coming into the game now is
just a real pain
so i play g4 which is correct i have to
try to undermine these really strong
pawns of his
so king e6 king power exactly
so i take on f5 and here i make kind of
an interesting choice
once again i think that now maybe i
wouldn't play this move
uh because nowadays like i would really
like back then i remember thinking that
okay i have to try to draw this position
i remember thinking that now
because i i didn't really like my rxe1
move after i played it
so i liked his king better so i thought
okay you should be trying to draw
so i thought okay trade as many pawns as
you can i should preface this by saying
that should draw
the way i played should be okay but i
also think
that it's not really necessary because
his pawn on e4 is actually a weakness i
would say
so for example if i play something like
king f1 and just say march my king to e3
probably i'm just gonna draw pretty
easily right like the epon is just kind
of weak here
and i don't think i would really
struggle to draw this too much
but i don't know i mean bishop f4 check
it's not that clear
uh i did play f3 yes uh and again i
don't think it's a bad move
i should still draw fairly comfortably
to be perfectly honest
but it's also um
not so easy now like it's definitely
becomes
you know more complicated so
takes on f3
king f2 bishop back to d6
and here
king takes f3 and again
we have enough reduced material it it's
getting closer and closer to a draw but
at the same time it's also getting close
to a position where i have to be very
careful
so he took and played rook c6
and once again i would say that i'm the
definitely the one who has to be careful
the problem when you review games like
this with a computer is they tend to
just say zero zero zero zero zero
all the time and i'm not saying they're
wrong but
it also means that you're the one who
has to play accurately here
and i really think that at this position
uh i should probably play the move h4
now i was understandably hesitant to
push pawns but the fact is that
preventing black from playing putting a
pawn on g5 and playing this way is
actually kind of nice
because say if black plays g5 now i can
simply take it
and then say bring my rook back and i
think that my
it's just really hard to ever win
because black can try to go after my
pawn
but the problem is that he's just i'm
way too close so even though yes black
is definitely better
i am i draw by a couple tempi here so my
king gets to be one easy draw
uh actually that's a great question so i
expected him to play g6 i should point
this out
i expected g6 but i think his move is
quite a bit stronger
because if he does this now and i go for
this
this is now a really really good idea
and this is kind of why i played it in
the game
by the way because after takes king here
now his f pawn is actually a bit of a
weakness
believe it or not and his pawns are just
split and a lot weaker in a position
like this
so i actually think this is what i
planned and this is what i think is
actually
good for me
so i actually think that the way he
played with king e6 was underestimated
and probably a better try to win again
it's all drawn right so it's all kind of
relative
but that's at least what i would say
about it
so takes on f5 takes
f3
so yeah f1 i mentioned f3 i've come out
so yeah h4 i think would be clear and he
could play something like g6
h5 and try to win that way but quite
honestly it's just very difficult
because
his pawns are always going to be kind of
weak and i could try to always attack
them with my rook for example
so it's just going to be very very
difficult for him to ever try to win
this i would say
again i don't want to say that it's that
easy right because it's obviously not
but probably h4 would be a better try
um to draw here so
uh but but chest king what i mean is
that black's definitely better here
because
like okay i'm the one who has to try to
draw right so i'm not like dead equal
yet right
the computer will say zeros because it
is a draw but i'm the one who has to
draw with accurate play black is not
so that's what i mean by black is better
um
so rook foreck king to e6
rook g4 is what i tried and this i'd say
is a lot less accurate
but even after g5 even here i think that
i could have this was the last moment i
could have really secured a drawj
position by force
and the question is what move should i
play here because the move i chose was
definitely wrong
oh the king of pawn in game yeah you can
call that a draw you don't get to say
why it's really better
black's really better there i would say
so
so what would you do here is white
because again it's kind of a tricky
situation
but
so h4 is what i played unfortunately
which turns out not to be so accurate
um to be honest already i was very
unhappy with my position and i probably
didn't look for my resources enough
uh terry you're correct rook b4 is a
very very good move here
because if rick c4 king d5 i haven't
really helped myself
but rook b4 is actually quite good and
the idea is that if takes of course then
rook b6 check
i could take on a6 and it's quite a draw
most likely
so he plays oops so king d5 is a better
try
and now i play king g4 and believe it or
not this position is probably just drosh
because he can play rook takes c5 but
then rook here and takes
and this position is just so hard to do
anything because he has to defend the g5
pawn all the time so even though we have
a couple extra pawns on the board
the extra pawns actually make the draw
easier for me not harder because say if
king d4
right i could just play rook g6 and i'm
not even threatening to take
i just am waiting so like king d3 i just
play here
and i basically just wait and the
problem is if the rook moves this way
then his pawn hangs if the rook moves
this way then this pawn hangs
and there's just no good way to move the
rook and if you can't move that a5 rook
it's going to be
pretty tough to win
and black could play king take c5 but
now i simply can go back with the rook i
think
and there's just not really much to do
the king goes to h5 and again like
you're just not really you can't ever
really make a threat
because my king is just so active and so
strong and
to ever get winning chances there would
be quite good
huh uh yeah no problem i'll go goodie
uh okay so h4
you're welcome guys i am glad you uh
enjoy the content here
but believe it or not there's still some
tricks to go this game
the complexity like the fact is that the
middle game was complex in this but i
think the end game
was even more complex and i won't have
time to go through
every single detail in this end game
believe it or not it is so complicated
but rook takes c5 was played
and now rook b4 king d5 and maybe here i
should just play rook b6 immediately
just so his rook has to go back because
his h6 pawn hangs
and then just come back and maybe this
was a better try but okay i took the
pawn and played king g4
which i thought was logical at the time
and here
he again made things unnecessarily
complicated
he could have just taken this pawn and
honestly this position is probably just
very good for him
so for example if i try rook b6
trying to you know help myself here he
plays this
and if i go rook here he plays check
and the problem here is that these pawns
are just so hard to actually stop
and even if he ends up sacrificing one
of them like here he doesn't have to
it's just even if i take one of them
right like
the problem is that he's just too fast
he plays his rook up he plays his pawn
up
and my pieces are just not in the right
position even remotely here
so a position like this even i think
rook a1 is correct
and the problem is a5 like even if i try
to bring my king back
a5 this pawn is just coming way too fast
and my king is not going to be nearly
good enough here
so a position like this usually you're
able to win
um i believe pretty pretty effectively
but i think that this is just something
he was not sure of so in the game he
played rook b5 which may be good enough
but it gave me some hope so i played
rook a4 and believe it or not this is a
case where again
i don't fully understand all of this end
game but i think it's very important for
him to play king d6 so that if i play
rook a1
he can play the move rookie five and now
he's able to bring his king over to
safety and his rook on e5 is very very
good
the problem with his king e6 move is i
play rook a1
and now all of a sudden it's not so easy
for him to actually do this
so he gets kind of a similar situation
to that like he'll play a move like
rookie five later but the problem is
that his king becomes very passive
he tries king f6 oh rules of thumb it's
really really difficult
like um
yeah oh i would say you cannot simplify
rook and pawn against rook and i'll show
you why like even in the game it becomes
immensely complicated i would say that
you generally want to have an eye on the
pawn and be able to check from the side
uh if you can get your key in front of
the pawn obviously you draw that way but
like if your king's on the side you
often draw but there are times when the
rook can cut you off
there's also a rule where if you have a
rook cutting off the pawn here
and they cut you off on the e file you
lose but if they cut you off on the d
file you draw
which sounds really strange it would
take a while to explain all of it
but there are lots of different rules i
would say though that every situation is
a bit unique
so you can't just use one rule of thumb
for all the positions you have to be
you have to calculate them very well and
you'll see this because again like
think about this swat like is extremely
experienced gm he studied countless rook
end games and
he actually ended up messing up this
rook game at the very end
i wasn't able to take advantage but even
very very strong players get this wrong
so
to simplify it is very difficult you
have to just really learn them
uh quite well the specific situations
but here i came up with a good idea i
decided to
part with my a pawn check and then just
sit
and the problem he realized here is that
sitting is actually quite annoying
because once again his rook on a5 is
just very very passive here i can't
really move
so he tries to shoot away my rook but
the fact is that it's not so easy to
actually do that
because now i just give checks and he
goes back
and now he comes up because he realizes
that he can't make progress unless he
brings his king up and sacks the jeep on
so this is the only real way to try to
play for a win here
so he does it i take the pawn rook a1
and this was a really crucial decision
for me
how should i try to draw this and a lot
of this
is about knowing your rule with these
end games
so how would you try to draw heroes
white what move would you play
because this is largely about knowing
these end games really well and i have
to confess
i knew i didn't know rook end games too
badly i worked on them a lot with my
first coach so
and i studied the endgame manual and
stuff but this end game was a little
weird with my king up and i have to
definitely say that i didn't
know these apon things as well as i do
now um
back then but even now i would say i
could definitely screw this up because
it's really easy to do
um all right
rook a5 is possible but keep in mind his
king wants to move up anyway so unless i
have a specific idea in mind rook five
doesn't really help me
i gave my like it's helpful to look at
these positions with the table base but
the problem is that
it'll give you sometimes draw like if
you have lots of drawing moves it'll
sometimes give you drawing moves which
you should never ever play because
they're so complicated like
there's usually a good or known way to
try to draw it which is what a human
being can grasp onto
so rook f3 then king f5 doesn't really
help you i don't think because the king
will simply park itself on d4
and then push the a pawn and i think
that that's going to be very very
difficult
to draw because your king on f5 doesn't
actually do that much
so again i can't say for sure whether
things are drawing or winning because
even these like this position is that
complicated it looks simple
but
yeah i definitely like the thing is i
would say the side checks are what you
want
this is a very good rule of thumb for
you guys you want to be hitting your
opponent's pawn
the main reason for this is it makes it
very difficult for them to ever move
their rook to say d1 if they could play
rook d1
and shield their king say and do it this
way they'd probably win pretty easily
but it's very important to keep their
king to that pawn so my rook is actually
already on a good square
so really i actually want to improve my
king more than anything else
so you can't go to that file because
this would be just embarrassing
i just lose right take take and i'm with
in the square but unfortunately this
king cuts me off so i just lose
so the best move here is king g4
because the rook has to stay glued to
this pawn now
and that's really the key so he can play
rook g1 check but after king h3 he
hasn't actually solved anything
he either has to bring the rook back or
he has to go here but now i just keep
giving checks right
so i'll just check check for a million
years and if he tries to come too close
now i'll probably exactly actually which
way am i going here
now i think i come back right and the
idea is that if his rook comes back
that's great
but now i just sit here and the problem
he has is that
he really can't make progress like he
can come after my rook right
but it's going to be very very tricky to
actually do anything so let's say he
comes here
and comes here and i'm just sitting
right
if he tries to come after my rook this
way i go this way
if he comes here i have to not allow
this right but i just come back
and even though my king's cut off so
much like how does he actually make
progress
so what does he actually do here right
he has to probably try to go backwards
and then after check check
check maybe try to put his king here
but now he's going to have a trickier
time i guess he can try this but then i
come here
i have to make sure this is a move
though i guess that's very important
so i don't even know if this is the best
way to try to draw because my kings cut
off a very long
way here guys so maybe this is actually
not the clearest draw
but i would say uh here
what's the best way to do this actually
ah maybe it's actually just to attack
the pawn from the side so something like
this may be clearest yeah yeah
so if the rook moves back my king moves
back if here i just attack from the side
again
here attack from the side again so
notice how the pawn can't go up so you
have to come back
and now i can simply park my king here
and this is a known draw with my rook's
hitting the pawn and my king's here
so this is probably a bit better
so anyway this is very complicated stuff
though and needless to say because i'm
definitely going to be getting this
wrong myself sometimes
but okay a5 would be the logical attempt
to win and now once again you could
check
putting the rook here very important
and then king here so the same idea
right here
you can play rook at 4 check but this is
probably the simplest because again i
have this idea
and if king here i play here to make
sure i have this idea
always line up with the pawn because if
you ever allow the rook to leave that's
how you lose right
so you have to make sure the rook can
yeah so i'll demonstrate it because it
can happen in the game right
but the basically known the known draw
goes like this you go here
and you're hitting the pawn from the
side so the whole idea is that this is
called the ventura defense
so the whole idea is that if they check
you you go here if they go here you just
wait
and the whole point is that if they try
to go near the pawn
so say they do this now you just to give
checks till the end of time
and you actually can check this way
pretty much to the end of time
if they go here for example if they try
to go to here
now you can just move somewhere right so
say rook b3
if check you go up if here they go back
if rookie before you check
and this is kind of the known drawing
position the known drawing motif right
so i actually want to go because i want
to ask you one last question because
in the game i played a bad move i played
the move rook f2 which is kind of silly
i wanted to bring my king in
but this is absolutely the wrong trying
to draw so he plays a5 i play kg4
yeah here i realized that this was just
not gonna cut it like if i play here he
can simply go here
and i'm just doing nothing my king's not
going anywhere if check here
i can't even go king here because he
checks me right
so i have to move again and then he goes
here and then i realize my king's just
terrible
so this would just be not what i wanted
so i tried king g4
a4 rook f5 check king g3
a3 he's playing it well so far
but then this was the moment if he plays
king e4 he actually wins pretty simply
and eventually he did
eventually he figured it out and i
actually knew this at the time
so i knew that i was losing here because
this position i knew was a loss
but then he played king e2 and i thought
but i had about five minutes
and i could not figure out
like how i could draw this
but i actually do have a drawing method
here and i wanted to give you guys an
opportunity to find it because it is
crazy
so white to play how do you draw this
position
because i saw the correct move but i
missed one really really nasty idea
which is really really a funny one
actually
it's really funny though right like the
the middle game was so complicated but
the most
complicated part of this game and most
interesting part was maybe even this at
rook end game where we had rook and pond
against rook
that's correct chess king so you play
rook b3
and this holds against a lot of things
if check you have
king h2 if and if the king were on g2 by
the way this would be a known defense
with the king on g2 i knew it was a draw
but i thought with the king here i lost
because i saw that after
rook g one check king here i could draw
because if here i can check and take
this pawn right
no problem so what the move i didn't
like was a2
and here i thought that the problem is
if if rook here with the king here you
draw easily right
but in this position you can't because
now i can simply check here in queen
the question is what draw did i missed
oh queen versus rock and game now
honestly i think with a for a human
being have playing rook versus queen
when you have no time is just impossible
but white has a really really amazing
draw here
and yes queen versus look as a ross for
the rook i would say that playing with
the rook with no time is almost
impossible also it's easy to just lose
it
um but then again of course the chances
of drawing are not zero
um but okay i actually have a technical
draw here
and it's a really funny idea if you
haven't seen it and i think at the time
i had not seen this idea so i just
completely blanked it to be again to be
fair i had like under five minutes so
it's really hard to find all this
one of the things i don't like about
modern time controls like this this time
control was longer but i would say more
modern type controls like you just have
no time when you get an end game so you
can never play it well which i kind of
hate
so rook p2 is correct but the question
is what do you do after because let's
say king d3 right
i can't check again because then here
i'm just gonna lose
um i can't play king g2 because now
simply rook
check and queens and now i lose
so what do i play
so
very nice so now because there's no rook
g2 check
rook g1 check he actually has no way to
move the rook or pawn
so he can try this trying to go here but
now i play kg4 and the funny thing is i
can just check him like this so if he
tries to go here i give a check
if here i could come back and believe it
or not this idea draws
because if he tries to come close to the
rook i stay here if he tries to move
away i go here and then i do this
so believe it or not this is actually a
draw
alas in the game i did not find this
i played rook f2 check king e1 rook f3
he plays rook a2
and unfortunately now again i have the
opportunity to play rook b3 and draw
but i played rook f2 check and finally
he found the right idea and i did see
this during the game and i was hoping he
wouldn't
realize it but this position is a is
actually a win because i have to put the
rook on a4
is the problem my rook needs to be on f3
with my king
here that's the draw but because here i
have to do this i just don't have a
choice if i try to go back now he can
simply check me and play here right
and then i lose so i have to go to a4
and now he simply slides his king over
and i'm too slow like
i can play king g2 i did this right
but if i play king g2 now i'm simply too
slow because if here
i just don't have time to slide the rook
over if i try to go here he simply goes
here for example
just for instance and now i just lose
right because if i go here
his rook goes here here and his king
comes up and this is just lost
so very unfortunate i don't know if d1
is the best square maybe c1 slightly
more accurate but it's the same concept
right
so there's just no way to actually draw
this position i try this
yeah rook g2 is pretty funny huh but
it's a nice way to draw
so i just tried to bring my king closer
but unfortunately he's one tempo too
quick because he has rook b1 and this is
where the rook cutoff doesn't work by
the way when he has rook to b1 this is
the best square for the rook
so if i if his rook were like here it
would be a draw
because his rook could never get to b1
without allowing me closer
but because his rook's on b1 already
it's already a loss so here rook b3
i try here but now he simply plays king
b2
king here i can't trade rooks
a2 and i resigned because of course i
could try to play like
rook here but the problem is then he
plays rook b2 check i have to go up
and then king up king up king up there's
just nothing i can do here
and thus i lost one of the most crazy
games probably in my career but it was a
lot of fun to play
this game it was it kind of reminds me a
lot of one of the
a lot of the things i enjoy about
playing chess too
and i hope you guys enjoyed it and could
kind of learn from my mistakes and
uh it was again it was a really fun game
and
just a lot of fun to to play around with
it
so i hope you guys enjoyed it and stay
tuned for my next lecture
which is on uh a game from the
candidates
so stay tuned i'm gonna put that up
right away
it was painful but at the same time like
i really it wasn't a great tournament
for me overall it just i didn't play
that well so
the tournament was disappointing but i
was never really
sad about playing this game because i
thought it was such a fun game to play
and i enjoyed going over it i learned a
lot from it so it's the kind of game
that you actually really liked playing
even though you lost
there are plenty of losses which were
far more painful i would say